joining us now Cass Sunstein he teaches
at Harvard University's Law School also
the author of impeachment a citizen's
guide and joining us to talk about that
topic also should mention that he worked
in the Obama administration as the
former administrator of the White House
for office of information professor good
morning good morning to you
so why the book and why the book now
well the real reason for the book is
that my family and I moved to Concord
Massachusetts to a house that was
actually one of the places British
soldiers went on April 19 1775 and that
got me kind of fixated on what happened
on that fateful day and the events that
led to the American Revolution and the
period between the Revolution and the
Constitution I'd been studying
impeachment for approximately 20 years
but I hadn't kind of understood the
centrality of control of the chief
executive to the project that let's say
animated and fired up the colonies late
in the 18th century that's the
historical reference you write in the
book this also saying impeachment lay at
the core of the founders intricate and
majestic effort to balance the defining
Republican commitments the liberty
equality and self-rule it is ironic that
impeachment regarded in 1787 as an
essential component of the ballots is
now little understood by the people of
this country can you expand on that yes
so the great Alexander Hamilton won a
smashing victory in Philadelphia which
was to get a powerful president who
could do a lot of stuff and that was
deemed on balance to be essential given
the fact that the u.s. kind of went into
trouble after the Revolution because we
didn't have a chief executive but people
were very worried that we were having
the fetus of monarchy as it was called
or an elective monarchy and betraying
the principles for which people had lost
their lives in the revolution and one of
the safeguards that meant that we would
be having a Republican not a monarchy
was the power of impeachment I think
without impeachment the Constitution
would not have been ratified and
certainly a lot of people in that
Philadelphia convention would have
thought that their document was fatally
flawed what do you think that what do
you think impeachment means to most
people today and what is it actually
compared to the perception of what it is
I think it means one of three things the
first it's an obscure word that might
have to do with fruits or England or
something the second possibility is that
the House of Representatives kind of
gets to do what it wants which is what
Gerald Ford thought that by the way is a
big mistake the grounds for impeachment
or anyone else are sharply limited by
the Constitution and the third view is
that which speaker Pelosi actually said
not long ago is that if the president
has committed a crime he can be
impeached that's doubly wrong there are
lots of crimes that aren't impeachable
if the president jaywalks or if the
president shoplifts he's not impeachable
and there are things that are short of
crimes such as going on vacation in
Paris for six months
that's impeachable or abusing the pardon
power that's clearly impeachable and
neither of those things are crimes so as
far as specifics then what are
impeachable offenses I want to have
maybe one general category and then a
few examples Alexander Hamilton talked
about abuse of trust and another way to
put it is abuse of power so if you have
something where the president exercises
his legal authority in a way that is
egregiously wrong or abusive that's kind
of the category we're talking about and
think of the Declaration of Independence
that's a good clue about what
impeachment is about some examples would
be first and foremost a bridging civil
rights and civil liberties that was
called out in Massachusetts a good place
for it to be called out because that's
where the revolution started during the
ratification debates as a ground for
impeachment another thing would be to
neglect your authority in some terrible
way not to pay attention to the laws not
to pay attention to your obligation so
that would also be impeachable if you
were acting in a way that was kind of
going after your political opponents not
because they're wrong on the merits but
because they kind of belong in jail or
they belong being harassed by the
Internal Revenue Service that would also
be the domain of the impeachable
anything that involves corruption or
entanglement with foreign enemies that's
kind of at the core of what they were
worried about back in the
18th century past Sunstein joining us to
talk about his book impeachment a
citizen's guide and if you want to ask
him questions about it and the topic two
oh two seven three seven zero triple
zero one four Democrats two oh two seven
three seven triple zero two four
Republicans and four independent two oh
two six two eight zero two zero five
what's starting
edie in Washington DC line for Democrats
you're on with Professor cass sunstein
go ahead professor how you know very
good professor i am a scientist retired
in the space agency and I've done a lot
of research on the electoral college and
I'm very concerned about our commander
in chief the number forty five right now
and the thing that the chaos that this
country has been put through we were in
a crisis right now and I have difficulty
understanding why this president is
allowed to in the office that he holds
and demagogue what the scientists have
even even Ernest Hopkins of famous
scientists in England said he was asked
about the president mister Kennedy
seemed to be a demagogue appeals to the
lowest common denominator and I'm a
scientist not feel that way and I have
difficulty professor could you explain
to us how he's allowed to do this thing
why you're now to even find a spigot of
water in bed early Thank You professor
go ahead okay good so I've spent most of
the last year in the eighteenth century
and I haven't focused as much as many
people have on current events so I can
say that if a president is a demagogue
or if he signs executive orders he is
not impeachable for that reason if he
commits a high crime and misdemeanor we
can talk about that he is impeachable we
have had many presidents who at one time
or another have been characterized
fairly or not as demagogues and if the
characterization is fair that's
not good but that's you know part of the
political process signing executive
orders goes way back and executive
orders are a legitimate way of managing
the executive branch so if President
Trump says I want to restrict the flow
of new regulations and here's an
executive order by which my cabin is
going to be disciplined that's
completely fine that's something that
all presidents recent presidents have
done some version of that and so long as
it doesn't override the will of Congress
that that's all right so I hear the the
caller and I appreciate the concerns and
ordinarily the democratic process is the
mechanism and the ballot box is the
place where concerns of that kind are
expressed Edie I'm sorry Robin New York
Democrats line Rob go ahead good morning
thank you for c---span you know the
obvious question is is visit an abuse of
power to have fired call me the FBI
director and would it be an abuse of
power if this president dare step up and
try to fire Mueller and you know I think
it's a tremendous threat to our
democracy to try and discredit our
journalists and our news newspaper
our news people and I just think it's
insulting and to this whole business of
fake news is just it has a has a feeling
of authoritarianism they are Probert Rob
thank you okay so the Constitution
allows impeachment for high crimes and
misdemeanors
James Madison actually with whom it's
not wise to argue about the meaning of
the Constitution described the want and
discharge of meritorious officers as an
impeachable offense he said that very
early in the Republic so whether it's
Obama or some future Democratic
president or
Ragan or the current president these are
fair questions to ask to fire the FBI
director under ordinary circumstances
and even under not very ordinary
circumstances is not an impeachable
offense the FBI director is an at-will
employee of the president which means
the president can get rid of the FBI
director now if you get rid of the FBI
director for certain reasons that have
nothing to do with his job performance
but have to do with let's say the
rectitude and correctness of his
investigation of you then we at least
have a conversation to be had in the
particular circumstances of the Comey
discharge it would be I think very
challenging to make an argument that the
discharge was an impeachable offense he
was a very I think in my view Jesus has
had an extremely distinguished career
but he was a very controversial figure
by the time he was discharged and for
any president to on a new start is not
an impeachable offense rather whether or
not it's a good offense to fire the
current special prosecutor that is
Robert Mueller would be very grave act
and the reason is that it would be very
hard at first glance to generate a good
faith justification for getting rid of
him which is independent of wanting to
insulate oneself and one's operation
from what is otherwise a lawful
investigation so what just to call out
potential act as impeachable whether the
president is Republican or Democrat is a
very severe thing to do and for someone
like yours truly who worked for
President Obama to say something like
that about a successor you should be
very cautious about so I'm going to
phrase it very cautiously that is a
discharge of the current special
prosecutor would legitimately initiate a
discussion of whether the criteria for
impeachment are met and I'm phrasing
that very cautiously professor is there
are there lessons we learn about the
impeachment process then from the
impeachments of prep presidents Jackson
Nixon and Clinton yes
so the
Johnson and Clinton impeachment lessons
are kind of- lessons they're like anti
precedents where Johnson was actually
impeached for firing a cabinet had and
he had a right to do that and so that
was a an impeachment on which history
looks unkindly it was an illegitimate
impeachment and Clinton you know what he
did was not innocent or fine if he did
in fact perjure himself or obstruct
justice as was charged but those aren't
impeachable offenses that is to obstruct
justice or to engage in perjury with
respect to a private lawsuit for sexual
harassment no one should minimize the
gravity of those acts but that's not
what Hamilton and Madison and others
were thinking about when they were
thinking of high crimes and misdemeanors
that dramatical stirry and involved
abuse of distinctly presidential power
the Nixon case is a is a much stronger
one and there were diverse articles
there but the lesson of history is if
the president uses the apparatus of
federal government to oppose his
political adversaries there we are right
in the core of what the impeachment
clause was about and if the president
uses the apparatus of the federal
government to try to stop what would
otherwise be legitimate investigations
into the wrongdoing of his own operation
and possibly himself then we have a
serious impeachment discussion this is
al in Ohio Republican line good morning
I appreciate so a couple little quick
questions is a since it was sent that's
in the news now now what's what Trump is
going on in conclusion with the Russians
now is that impeachable or in the same
question is has anybody ever beat
impeach for this before conclusion thank
you these are terrific questions and
this is a particularly good one so as I
say that it's good to have a kind of
neutrality in investigating impeach
so if you are an opponent of President
Trump in the sense that you didn't vote
for him you should kind of try to
bracket that and think what I think this
act was impeachable if I loved them and
voted for him and if you are a fan of
President Trump and you've supported him
it's a good kind of reality check to
think if I disliked him very much and if
he was my least favorite politician what
I think he was impeachable for the act
in question that's a way of kind of
ensuring that you're being objective so
on the particular question if a
low-level adviser of a presidential
candidate interacts with an unfriendly
nation to try to get intelligence let's
say on a political opponent then
certainly if the candidate didn't know
about it and wasn't responsible for it
can't impeach the guy that's just you
know a terrible and the traitor is act
by a subordinate and the president's
can't be charged for that on the other
hand and this does go back to the
founding period if a candidate democrat
or republican interacts with an
unfriendly nation or acts corruptly in
such a way as to procure the presidency
then we are in the domain of the
impeachable so I'm going to be super
hypothetical here and use a use a
politician other than a current one
let's suppose a future Democratic
candidate works with China to find out
information about a Republican candidate
and exposes that information rather true
or false to the public in order to
discredit the Republican opponent and it
involved a secret interaction with China
to try to elicit that information then
that is that is definitely an
impeachable act that's the kind of thing
they were thinking about back in
Philadelphia from Frank and North
Carolina independent line yeah hi good
morning thank you for taking my call and
enjoy c-span every morning
[Applause]
my question is with regards to the use
of the term enemy nation or unfriendly
nation because I constantly have these
discussions with people who are calm
supporters who are all of a sudden such
great friends with the Russians and just
love them so much because their cult
leader likes him as well and how do we
define the term enemy nation or
unfriendly nation is it a occasional
term or is it a well defined so that we
can determine whether or not those trees
are not based on it okay so if we are
talking about you know formal
international relations then there would
be definitions that we could use I'm
speaking and I think many people are in
the context of Russia not in terms of
any formal term in international law but
in terms of ordinary language about our
relationship to describe a nation as an
enemy is pretty categorical and to do
that is arguably appropriate for some
nations on the globe I think it's better
to say unfriendly and I say that
notwithstanding the fact that you know
the Russian people are over history
great friends of the American people and
I'm talking about individuals and often
cities and you know these are close
friends across the world Americans and
Russians but the leadership of the
Russian government and the leadership of
the American government have been
unfriendly and that continues to this
day our ambassador to the United Nations
has had some pretty tough things to say
about about Russia and so Russia is not
like Canada or France in the sense that
they are not you know in close allies of
ours so if Russia is trying to intervene
in our election as evidently it did and
if a presidential candidate did and
there's no evidence as of now that he
did though there's evidence one of his
subordinates did
trying to take advantage of Russia's
intelligence gathering capacities to
defeat a political opponent that would
be very grave and the nation is
unfriendly in the sense that they are
not working as our ally across a range
of the most important questions in the
world today if a president is impeach
must he leave office and if not how does
it impact the the administration of the
office a impeachment is like an
indictment so we had some indictments
this week and that doesn't mean anybody
has to do anything except face a permit
process then there's a trial in the
Senate where the Senate acts and it's
very majestic if it's working right the
Senate is acting like a court and has to
convict by a two-thirds majority that's
the point in which the president has to
leave office there are certain kinds of
acts and I think the Nixon case was one
where even a serious impeachment inquiry
is let's say a sufficiently loud signal
that for the President to remain in
office voluntarily would be a mistake
there are other cases like that of
Clinton where the contestation was so
highly politicized
that the president stayed and so is it
simplistic to say if the Senate does the
trial the house brings the charges
that's accurate the house is acting and
quite like a prosecutor though it has
made an independent kind of judicial
decision that impeachment is appropriate
and then the house helps manage the
proceeding in the Senate which has to
convict and that's the term by a
two-thirds majority so we have in our
Constitution kind of two big safeguards
of the president against let's say
losing his job because Congress doesn't
like them the first is the high crimes
and misdemeanors standard and we've
talked about how that can be met by
things like you know invading liberty or
abuse of the pardon power or interacting
with other countries in certain ways
that's it's a high standard and then
there's an institutional protection
majority in the house two-thirds in the
Senate Cass Sunstein of Harvard Law
School
also the author of impeachment a
citizen's guide Thomas in Ohio go ahead
yeah what does it take to the steps to
get to the twenty-fifth amendment and
what a fabulous question the 25th
amendment is another Avenue by which the
president can be relieved of his
obligations and here or his his duties
and here there are two different ideas
the first is the twenty-fifth amendment
is about an ability to perform the job
we rather than about bad acts so think
of the 25th amendment as not about
actions but instead about condition so
if the president is suffering some
terrible physical or mental disability
then the president can be removed via
the 25th amendment that's what it's for
so it was done in the aftermath of the
Kennedy assassination and a thought was
what if President Kennedy had been shot
but had lived then what would we do if
he couldn't do the job 25th amendment
gives the answer so the the mechanism by
which that inability is triggered unless
Congress changes it but in the 25th
amendment this is how it is the vice
president and a majority of the cabinet
has to decide to that the president
can't do the job anymore and notice that
that's a pretty tough burden because the
vice president and the cabinet are going
to be pretty loyal to the president and
they're not going to want to say you
can't do your job anymore
or even initiate that conversation
unless the president is really
struggling with some kind of impairment
you talked about in the book a story how
you learned about the the impeachment
process and this from the Reagan
assassination attempt can you briefly
tell that story yes so I was a kind of
kid lawyer in the Reagan administration
and my boss early on tapped me on the
shoulder and said please learn about the
25th amendment and write it up and I
didn't say what I thought which is what
the heck is the 25th amendment I
actually didn't know which is
embarrassing they're kind of supposed to
know and then I did write it up but I
thought it was a bookish exercise what
this have to do with anything we were
trying to run a government and this was
like an academic exercise
a month later President Reagan was shot
we were watching the very cheerful
upbeat TV stories that said he was fine
and my boss tapped me on the shoulder
and said remember that 25th amendment
memo and I said yeah and he said it's a
lot worse than they're saying
President Reagan's in trouble and you
have to send memos over to try to
transfer responsibility to the vice
president do you know how to do that and
I said I think I remember that he said
well good you're in charge here and then
he ran off to the White House and with
my little fingers I don't think my voice
had quite changed yet I was very young I
was in charge of transferring power we
didn't have to do that for reasons that
I think are still not fully public but
it was very much on the table John in
Texas Republican line good morning
standing back from obviously the other
side of the party here I find it almost
hysterical or like 1984 to have
Professor talking about impeaching I do
the elected president when his wife who
was Samantha powers did more in masking
and violate the Constitution under Obama
and he was one of Amoz closest advisors
and violated the law more than anybody
else this man has no right to be on TV
talking about impeachment well integrity
of the election that's only professor
Sunstein well I appreciate freedom of
speech in this country I'd make two
corrections my wife's name is Samantha
power not Samantha powers and it's not
that important there's a little bit
important and second I'm not speaking
unless asked about the any particular
current official my book doesn't mention
President Trump and really the focus is
on our constitutional system and my hope
is that whether you're Republican or
Democrat to appreciate the majesty of
what happened in 1770s and 1780s and
people put their life on their line in a
way that had
more risk I think in some ways than any
other time when American has put their
life on their line that is we were in a
country yet and to appreciate what
happened in that period that is
inspiring and whether you want to think
about impeachment in connection with any
particular president that's that's
really up to you that's what the the
Constitution gives we the people are the
bosses of the impeachment process Leo in
Louisiana independent line media not
vagina for some time I find that your
show is extremely informative and my
question is in reference to duly elected
officials that abide by Constitution and
laws in reference to discriminatory acts
and I'll give you a fact we have a
president there sitting and is a an
elected official and I will say multiple
what for one certainly Senator McCain
the basically states that domicile in
reference to this being this following
discriminatory acts stipulates that
because of his financial situation he
was able to dodge the draft or it into
the military I am a military veteran and
due to the fact that my Paris will not
financially suitable to do what he done
where he had a factor that stipulated he
had some type of medical illness then we
have a cemetery saying that is totally
against the law okay we'll leave it
there thanks okay well first thank you
for your service my dad served in World
War two my brother-in-law served in
Vietnam sore dad
attitude to you in terms of impeachment
this is I think extremely important and
not well understood that with one
exception actions that a president does
before becoming president are not
impeachable and the reason is pretty
simple which is that impeachment is for
abuse of presidential authority and you
can't abuse your authority if you aren't
president
so whatever anyone did you know Clinton
Reagan Nixon Lincoln whatever they did
before President it's not a basis for
impeaching them the one exception as
discussed is if you procure the
presidency by illegitimate means that
was actually discussed in the
Constitutional Convention as a basis for
impeachment and and there's a logic
there we have a self-governing Society
and procuring the president in a way
that's corrupt or illicit is
inconsistent with our capacity for
self-governance more can be learned from
the book impeachment a citizen's guide
Cass Sunstein joining us and thank you
for your time sir
thank you a pleasure